[Musique]
est-ce que la pandémie de kobe 19 aurait
été prédite prophétisé et annoncé
plusieurs années avant l'avènement du
nouveau coronavirus c'est ce que laisse
entendre des publications très partagés
sur les réseaux sociaux
voici trois exemples en rafale analysés
par mon collègue nicolas de rosa il ya
d'abord le cas d'un livre intitulé la
fin des temps publié en 2008 par la
voyante américaine servir brown vers
2020 une maladie ressemblant à une forme
grave de pneumonie se répandre à travers
le monde
s'attaquant aux poumons et aux branches
et résistant à tous les traitements
connus encore plus stupéfiante que la
maladie elle-même sera sa soudaine
disparition et sa réapparition dix ans
plus tard avant de disparaître pour de
bon
aussi rapidement qu'elle était apparue
mais parlons de sylvie robe blanche
voici quelques-unes de ses autres fosses
prédictions incluse dans un de ses
livres publiés en 2004 il y aura un
vaccin contre le sida en 2005
faut il n'y aura plus de simple rhume
vers 2009 ou 2010
ah j'oubliais sylvia brown a prédit
qu'elle allait elle-même mourir à l'âge
de 88 ans elle est en fait décédé le 20
novembre 2013
à l'âge de 77 ans dans le même registre
vous avez été nombreux à nous écrire à
propos d'une autre prophétie en
provenance cette fois ci d'un jeune
voyant indien cet adolescent se nomme à
bigard à l'inde dans une vidéo publiée
sur youtube en ou dernier visionner à
près de 5 millions de reprises quand
même il prédisait qu'en raison d'une
maladie
le monde entamerait une phase difficile
de novembre 2010 9 avril 2020 d'entrée
de jeu
mentionnons qu'à bigard à l'inde
explique que ces choix de dates sont
liées à l'alignement des astres
on est donc loin bien loin d'une base
scientifique solide en épidémiologie en
virologie ou en microbiologie par
exemple en terminant un autre exemple de
prophétie 10 est la comédie 19 dont vous
nous avez parlé travers vos courriels
s'est étendue avec un passage du livre
intitulé le nouveau rapport de la cia
commencera le monde demain si une
maladie pandémique se déclare ce sera
sans doute dans une zone à forte densité
de population de grande proximité entre
humains et animaux comme il en existe en
chine et qu'en dépit des restrictions
limitant les déplacements internationaux
des voyageurs présentant peu ou pas de
symptômes pourraient transporter le
virus aux autres continents
mais il faut comprendre que le nouveau
rapport de la cia n'est pas un livre qui
avait pour but de prédire l'avenir mais
plutôt d'évaluer les possibles scénarios
de tension dans le monde et les risques
planétaire prévisible je vous suggère de
jeter un coup d'oeil à l'article si
nicolas de rosa qui se trouvent sur le
site web des décrypteurs et un coup
parti bas derrière notre groupe facebook
ayant notre courriel qui est aussi là
pour vous pour toutes les questions que
vous avez au sujet de ce qui circule sur
le web
salut
[Musique]